no so um let's talk about the Gathering
because it is a it is a thing did you
ever see the Workaholics episode about
that [__] was hilarious yeah it was they
did it good too yeah it was good man
there's a movie that came out called
family MH and the character in the movie
is a jug right and she goes to the G
and they asked us to uh make a cameo and
be like we're on stage at man me me and
uh shagy are like what is this going to
be little rinky D [__] they rebuilt the
[__] Gathering you show up and you're
like oh [__] there was a rides right
carnival rides you know a crowd right
you know what I'm saying tents
everywhere people on golf carts partying
[__] fires I'm like how the [__] did
they do that you know what I mean it was
crazy and um yeah it was cool though man
you guys uh so I've had I've had lots of
friends perform I was trying to [__] the
chick from uh uh uh Orange Is the New
what is it Orange is the New Black yeah
[__] yeah she in that movie yeah I was
me and her dog we were [__] spit she
knows it she knows it yeah we were
spitting gang and and the other chick
was there from um um [__] and family
American Pie American Pie she was there
and um she knew it too yeah you know
what I mean and she was she kept going
like you know we were just spitting game
like talking like we weren't you know
anyway then um we talked on text for
like a month and then it
ended but we didn't K I didn't mean we
spitting game like yeah like we were
talking about [__] interesting [__] you
know what I mean I wasn't like I'mma get
in your panties and [__] [__] like hey
you got a mirror in your pants cuz I can
see myself in there
but it was dope though no I was going to
ask you so I've heard some okay so I
heard at the Gathering there's some
crazy [__] going on I've seen video of
the feet guy have you seen this guy he's
like the guy at the Gathering who like
licks all the chicks feet no man I ain't
seen
that I've heard about the drug bridge at
a certain point in time wasn't there a
drug bridge where like it was kind of I
wish there was still a drug Bridge there
should be it was like a nice like safe
open like everybody go know didn't get
your [__] I don't know man I just don't
want nobody to um you know get hurt and
die course of course of course this was
before I think we had to worry about
like Fentanyl and [__] this was
obviously years ago you know yeah
exactly yeah yeah and and then and then
um our good allegedly that's why I said
is allegedly these things didn't happen
this was not a thing we did no thing a
here's where it's not like on the it's
not like on the festival map there was
like drug Bridge it was just like it was
like a fan thing it's in the
program no and then um yo jelly roll
told told me about some sort of [__]
tent or something that was going on
allegedly there was a [__] tent that's
dope what's wrong with that nothing's
wrong with that there should be some in
several locations that we would love
wait a minute consent adult wait a
minute I'm sorry yeah that's actually a
[__] great idea a [__] tent what the
[__] we can provide like six tents on
the ground big red tents and light them
up all red right yeah and be like and
you go in there and it's just all lavish
and clean a place going and [__] you
know you're all in a wet tent you know
what I'm saying mosquitoes and [__] you
boys are right outside the nylon you
know what I mean you can go away to the
[__] tent you know what I'm saying you
guys for a small fee oh yeah like like a
little and then there's just like you
know willing lovelies in there you know
cuz all we're getting is a tent
consenting willing allegedly allegedly
consenting juglet I don't know what
that's actually dope like that's
actually a dope idea [__] time not a
terrible idea what's the craziest thing
is it really it's a bad idea no it's not
a bad idea what's the craziest thing
with your own eyes you've seen at the uh
at at the Gathering that you can talk
about allegedly that you allegedly saw
with your own eyes no man I I allegedly
nothing to Gathering is off the [__]
chain I dude I want to I want to [__]
go what's in the middle of Ohio right
bro listen I I
I really advise you to go on account of
this I know you're a wise man and
there's nothing worth more than
experiences memories for sure you know
what I'm saying and you will absolutely
never forget not if you live to be a
thousand right going to the Gathering
bro and and there is
absolutely no [__] danger right
that's the biggest misconception wait
didn't didn't somebody get booed off
stage it was was it Tila Tequila yeah
yeah I saw and then didn't who was
unless you're an artist unless you're an
artist and they don't like you cuz wow
what a weird thing I just said there's
no danger and then you're like what
about
t unless you're an artist absolutely
you're right there has been rappers that
they've thrown [__] at [__] yeah my
heroes bro i' I've seen man I've seen
some of my heroes go down and leave the
stage you know what I mean wow like who
Too Short oh they almost got Old Dirty
Bastard off oh and it was I believe the
last concert of his life wow oh you had
obb at the Gathering right before he
passed away yeah that's crazy were you
able to talk with him when he got there
who was up there somebody ran up there
with ODB that sounds and was like cuz
they were throwing [__] and ODB was
starting to get mad you know I I mean
they throw [__] that's what they do
they're not always trying to hit you
right they're just throwing [__] look at
in the air they throw [__] [__] flying
everywhere you know including at the
stage you know and some people don't
know how to do it other people like
yellow wolf that [__] caught a
you know and drank it in the place
popped you like [__] Stone Cold
catching a beer on the [__] exactly
the crowd loved it like he's he's saying
I got no problem with this I'm rocking
this you know what I mean and um that's
what you the kind of energy you have to
have cuz sometimes guys get up there and
they get they want a thug you know yeah
and that is of course the worst thing
cuz if you th on one
Jugo the Gathering of the good jugal
everyone's turning against you're in the
wrong place you know what I'm saying
yeah no as as that's crazy I didn't know
you guys had OD or even if you're up
there trying to act like you're too
harder than them right right right right
and you know what I'm saying the only
ones that ever got away with clearly
looking harder than them was [__] um
last
year who played last year the main
group I can't remember I'm getting so
dumb um not suicide boys the other um um
those dudes I know you talking about
city morg city morg yeah city city more
goes up there bro they killed it they
killed it [__] slat them wow like I
that's they love that Wicked [__] city
morg is is a a
a wicked [__] and suicide boys listen to
them they do that 36 mafia [__] yeah
it's like very [__] 36 suicide was a
very very 36 mafia style I feel like DJ
Paul's kind of adopted the Jugo SL
American pretty heavily me and DJ Paul
are actually [__] very close no he's
a great guy he's so [__] great man
you know what I'm saying we did an album
together he wouldn't stay at my house I
have my studios in in my front yard
right he wouldn't stay at my house
because he didn't like the woods I live
and he's like [__]
that I'm like what what do you think a
bear is going to jump through the window
or something that's crazy but he's the
[__] man he's so dope I love him man